you
this week on quadriga german coalition
crisis of confidence Chancellor Angela
Merkel's government is in danger of
plunging into crisis as the
investigation of a former member of
parliament but possible possession of
child pornography unfolds a cabinet
minister has resigned and could be
prosecuted for passing on information
that should have remained secret the
affair raises a tricky question is it
acceptable for a member of a government
to use privileged information to avert
harm from a future government your host
this week alyas lon hello and welcome to
quadriga the immensely popular and
successful us TV show house of cards has
just begun its second season and these
days in German politics were
experiencing our own version of house of
cards one that is not very easy to look
through that's why we have invited three
experts to explain what the situation is
and what ramifications could possibly
result out of it therefore welcome to
johannes light house' who is a broiling
correspondent for the German daily
newspaper frankfurter allgemeine zeitung
he has been with the epithet since 1988
and served previously as a papers London
correspondent Tony Paterson is the
Germany correspondent for the British
daily newspaper the independence he also
worked as a foreign correspondent in
Paris phone war show and Vienna and
Cathy annamaya is a correspondent for
the German public broadcaster ard where
she covers various political parties as
well as Chancellor Merkel she was
previously based in Washington DC where
she served as the AR DS us correspondent
warm welcome to you all Christiana Maya
as I said for us in Germany this very
little else that we talk about these
days particularly the political scene
though in the internet
so media if one falls it's not really
resonating this so-called scandal that
has Germany all up in arms these days so
let's look at the facts let's look at
the facts as we know them it all started
with the German agriculture for
agriculture minister hans-peter
Friedrich resigning because of something
that he did as interior minister perhaps
you can elaborate on that all right he
revealed a state secret he did that I'm
you real the secret that there was a
prosecution or at least an investigation
going on about one member of parliament
for child pornography so he revealed
that secret to his future coalition
partner which again he did for he claims
political reasons in order to to make
sure there won't be a political crisis
but he was not allowed to do that this
is why he resigned and the discussion
now is who knew what when and why and
who revealed what to whom and why and
who might have warned that member of
parliament who then consequently sort of
disappeared a resigned and also got rid
of all his computer hardware so this is
a real crazy situation and I think
there's a lot that has to be revealed
from her indeed a very peculiar
situation you on a slight house'
hans-peter Friedrich then interior
minister hans-peter Friedrich informed
the chief of the Social Democrats zigma
Gabrielle about as casiano manager said
about a investigation of SPD Member of
Parliament Sebastian adati for possible
possession of child pornography now this
information obviously then was passed on
by Sigma Gabrielle to within his own
party to now foreign minister Steinmeier
as well as SPD parliamentary Chief
Thomas Oppermann now the question now is
at the end of the day what laws were
broken here I think if in what laws were
broken what did hunts be definitely do
at the end of the day that caused
him to resign because here's the
question that a lot of people are asking
and not only within his own party was it
not human what he did at the end of the
day I think there is difference and
distinction that we have to make between
what's morally just and what's
judicially wrong well it might have been
justified in political reasons when you
marry your about to marry wife and you
know something in what that's going on
in her family that has come to your
knowledge because of your profession
then you might be inclined to tell her
but he was head he was the Minister of
the Interior he was head of the police
service and enter Tony serves in Germany
and because of this office he was
forbidden to talk about ongoing
investigations and he did and so he had
to face the consequences and resigned
that's crystal clear and that's a thing
of the past as we speak now because now
what's going on presently is the
political consequences of what he did
the his own party is a bit upset that he
acted for the benefit of another party
which had not to bear the consequences
but he had to bear the consequences and
resign so there are all kinds of
follow-up questions and bad feelings now
going on between the two polishing
partners that are forming the present
government Tony Paterson you are the
correspond and Germany correspondent for
the independent how much of this story
resonates with your audience if at all
very little in fact I haven't I've put
the story up offered it but I haven't
actually written the story about this
yet I may may have to I think we need to
go though back to the very beginnings of
it we've got a fairly prominent sbd
politicians Sebastian a dirty Indian
mother we've got a name for himself by
exposing some of these neo-nazi attacks
that have been going on here in germany
and was tipped
for a good place in the coalition
government of Chancellor Angela Merkel
then it emerged through Canadian
investigations into child pornography
and he was of a list of recipients of
possible child porn and it has emerged
at least have been suggestions that mr.
dartie received pornographic photographs
of underage boys posing this is not an
illegal thing in Germany but it does
raise the suspicion of child pornography
and therefore he is under suspicion and
therefore his he's disappeared I think
the main question in this whole thing is
through the information that was
supplied to the then interior minister
mr. Friedrich whether his conversations
to social democrat politicians resulted
in the fact that mr. ed RT was tipped
off by somebody in the Social Democratic
Party which is a very difficult and
contentious issue if that was the case
then that is a gross breach of
parliamentary trust and I think this is
the main issues at stake here and
kissena Maya the main issue there Tony
Paterson touched upon indeed if and how
and when the bus and a dirty was tipped
off into the fact that there was going
to be an investigation because what we
know now is that hard drives were
removed from his computer and destroy
before investigators could search his
home and his office yet we don't know
who tipped them off exactly we don't
know we have no idea and maybe we will
never find out because there were so
many people involved who knew about it
like all the regional police the local
police the federal police politicians
who had no business for that were
involved so who would eventually you
know find out who actually tipped him
off and he himself obviously gave an
interview to another media outlet where
he said he was not tipped off by his
political
so close peers or whatever you know
however you framed it I don't know and
so maybe you know the leak was somewhere
else but I think there are a couple of
other problems involved one is the rule
of law you know there is and has to be a
presumption of innocence because what we
know is he downloaded photos that are
not illegal so to say that he is under
suspicion is one thing to reveal it to
the public is another thing so in all
these discussions the presumption of
innocence has been downplayed so much
that I'm a little worried about that
that's one thing the other thing is what
do these politicians think how can the
Minister for the interior believe he
himself is above the law meaning spill
out the beans and give away a secret he
actually should treat as a secret to his
political opponent or future coalition
partner in this case and how could this
coalition partner then you know go on
and spill the secret to everyone else he
knows in his personal sort of political
party yeah these other questions isn't
this is the reality of politics anywhere
yet politicians are going to spill talk
about this kind of thing they gain to
mention it the problem here is that it
came out but i think mr. Frida's aim was
at the time at the time we have to look
at the fact that the two parties which
are now in coalition government
Chancellor Merkel's conservatives and
the Social Democrats were in in
negotiations which were going on for
months they were under pressure to reach
an agreement and form a coalition and
the fear was on the conservative side
that if they let somebody who is under
suspicion of dealing with child
pornography that this will result in a
scandal for the government what's
happened now is that keeping now that
cats out of the sack and now that's what
it's doing but perhaps not as bad as it
might have been back then you honestly
toys a husband of people he still claims
he did the right thing in an interview
he said look all I tried to do was to
avert harm from a future German
government they're not legitimate no of
course not not if you are
the position he had been in at the time
not if you are the Minister of the
Interior as we as we said previously but
the problem is perhaps he didn't feel at
that time still so much being in his
role because it was after the election
the government dragged on the one of the
coolest former coalition partner was
voted out of parliament so we were in a
very prolonged state of being in between
and perhaps he felt he might have
greater freedoms then then he actually
did but I think another thing comes into
play and this is the the the public has
been has wanted this great coalition the
two big parties in Germany forming the
government on one hand on the other hand
we've all been a bit wary because it is
in a way undermining democratic ways and
rules and the way politics normally
works and functions and he has given all
kind of justifying reasons fulfill these
prejudices you see but just disobeying
the law and and forming political I
don't know ways to to to to interact
with his future bodies in a way that is
not acceptable by if you look at the
rule of law I think we got an unexpected
view inside yeah you know which doesn't
happen often so without anybody knowing
all of a sudden we can look very closely
oh this is how they operate you know
they talk to each other and they have
these arrangements and little
understandings and it looks like being a
bit of part of a series the first thing
that went public this coalition partners
what they wanted to prolong the terms of
government election periods are four
years in this country normally they
wanted to extend it to five years which
is a kind of a part-time dictatorship
adding a future year to your reign
second thing was they were are rising
their wages so the pay for four members
of parliament is to be going up and
that's done very
very fast very discreetly and now we
have this Minister of the Interior
tipping off his future colleagues in
that way but may just come back to that
one again because the Minister of
Interior actually resigned which was
really good and I think a clean step and
move and all right but then he came back
and said well I would have done it all
over again and that was maybe not so
good anymore because i thought the
management of the crisis have been on a
good path and and now it's it's a little
tricky and i think that is something to
look into you know what does politic
allow itself to do you know because they
seem to think that in certain situations
they are not bound to the law like a
normal citizen and that is obviously
what upsets the people because they
saying hey hang on you know if you're
the Minister of Interior off the
Constitution basically you know who if
not you has to stick to the rules and
then he is no second guessing about that
and to make matters worse Tony Paterson
we now also know that SPD parliamentary
Chief Thomas Oppermann called the head
of the Federal Office of Criminal
Investigation the Baker obelisk on
island to confirm whether such
investigation into a Dottie's alleged
possession of child pornography is going
on or not now we have different versions
about what actually happened during that
conversation apparently the head of the
federal criminal bureau said that he
didn't say anything during the whole so
how a conversation took place I don't
know because nothing was said he didn't
ask anything that makes everything more
interesting i think that the overall
impression that's created is this this
italian phrase of the one hand washing
the other and this is not very nice this
sends the wrong image for the most
powerful country in europe that you've
got a government which is comprised of
the two main political parties and they
are in codes with each other they're
helping each other out this is the
message that's being sent abroad and
this is not very very tasteful not
saiful and certainly no winners
up until now you wanna slide toys ax the
one name that oddly hardly ever comes up
during the so-called scandal is that of
chance America a lot of people are
wondering what did she know if anything
at all and if he didn't know what kind
of message does it send if the
Chancellor the head of the government
doesn't know about these things going on
within her own government well she must
be happy she didn't know anything from
the beginning because otherwise she
would be in more trouble than than she
is now but you're right the but is it
possible that she didn't know yes of
course yeah I think the way freighter he
wanted to present himself when he gave
away this information was he wanted to
just to please this form of this the
future coalition pan and maybe he really
wanted to to keep his job you know there
were contenders for this post of
minister of the interior in the in the
future coalition party SPD and maybe
that played a role in the whole thing as
well but as in any crisis we the
incident is one thing and all the
consequences are the main thing then in
the following days and weeks and so I
think the main question for Merkel now
is how am I getting my government back
together and working because there is a
severe sense of mistrust now on both
sides but let me hace and assuming that
Chancellor Merkel did not know what kind
of message does it send that the head of
the German government doesn't know
what's going on with her own government
well I mean if you if we if you accuse
your Minister of the Interior that he
broke the law and you force him to
resign if he would have told you this
secret then she would be in trouble for
not acting at the time she she got the
news from him so the only the only way
to protect her is not to have known that
a colleague of her government broke the
law by giving away this information
shows so she can't be can't have been
informed if things were all right at the
time and maybe she wasn't I mean there's
always the possibility that foolish
totally underestimated the case and
thought he can sort of you know Warren
is colleagues and then it
the guy who is it's all about what would
kind of be in the sidelines and it would
not be a big scandal I think that is the
political intention it wasn't done very
well but it was probably his political
intention and maybe there's a certain
credibility that he did not run to the
Chancellor and say hey did you know you
know this member of parliament mm-hmm
but we don't know it and another major
question is since you brought it up why
did the SPD and Thomas Oppermann in this
case reveal the fact that Hans p
definitely passed on this information in
the first place I think that was the
attempt to actually manage the crisis
well because the last few crisis it was
always the case that information came
out sort of in very small portions so
this time he probably thought i would
all on the table and a that would
protect himself nice move be everything
will be out on the table and then people
can deal with it which he did in a way
and he claims that he has spoken to the
Minister of Interior about his press
publication and also to his peers from
the Social Democrats so he didn't it was
not upon meant by himself he's not
blamed for everything but it's I think
it's probably not fair because he
actually talked to everyone and said
this is what I'm coming out with are you
all right with this and really said yes
that's fine even though now he claims he
didn't understand it but anyway and the
other two steinmeyer the foreign
minister and Gary the the chief of the
SPD they both agreed to so they almost
same boat now they're all certainly in
the same boat now and it's a messy boat
to say the least just one brief word
perhaps about adati himself as you said
he was a rising star within the SPD many
people commended him even on the other
side of the political aisle commended
him for his leadership in which he
steered the investigation committee into
the so called NSU neo-nazi trial in
Germany there are even some conspiracy
theorists out there say this is payback
time this is payback time because he
revealed the shortcomings are and
failures of the German intelligence
authorities do you give any credence to
that well I mean if a Canadian
investigators
turn up through a very lengthy
investigation turn up evidence that mr.
a dirty had been accessing a form of
child pornography ER and say this
because in Germany this is this is not
illegal it's adolescents posing in
suggestive poses then it strikes me that
there must be something in it I mean
police don't make that kind of mistake
that easily and in this kind of
investigation so I think that's very
much sort of conspiracy theory type
stuff I think him he was on the fast
track and this is a major stumbling
block and not more than a stumbling
block at the end of his career but what
amazes me as an outside observer is the
fact that the issue of child pornography
with politicians seems to have partially
gone under in this in this case in Great
Britain there's been on running such
scandal about child pornography which is
going on for two or three years now
involving a leading television celebrity
who's now dead and all this information
is coming out and the public is much
more sensitized to this issue in Germany
it seems two ish the fact that you have
a politician who is suspected even
suspected of child pornography would be
an absolute scandal in Britain here it's
it's gone under the political
considerations in the energy agreed I
disagree I think it's still a scandal
the only thing is and there is a
distinction so far so far I say it's
only about photos that are legal so the
world child pornography implies
something more harsh some outside
outside of Germany who don't really
understand what what the boundaries here
are between legal and illegal so it
falls to me okay it's about posing
that's the word they use so if you and
and the pictures he supposedly loaded
down where pictures of naked boys age I
don't know 10 to 14 but they didn't pose
in a sexual way at least that is what we
hear why we all don't know that really
and and now the prosecutor says people
who download something like that might
download different things or might be
involved in child pornography but that's
only an assumption it's in
are proven so so far we are just talking
about legal photos and that is a point
that has to be clear and that's this
camel in itself and I mean the reason
why it's in the German present all over
the place is that people are scandalized
and that is why I said it is I disagree
but at the same time if it should turn
out to be real child pornography I think
then the scandal will be in digan I
think we will have it we will have a
debate on child pornography on stricter
stricter legal restrictions on the on
child abuse but we are still so
preoccupied with the the current
political implications that nobody has
just had time to sit back and say okay
we have to change things here anything I
toys this is no longer about a dirty
this is no longer about alleged
possession of child pornography but this
is about a full-blown crisis of
confidence this is about a full going
political crisis in Germany the two
months old grand coalition some people
even say is in jeopardy and new
elections could be on the horizons would
you support that thesis no I don't think
that will happen although some might
wish for it of course but I think well
as always if you have this crisis
everybody's trying to exploit it for his
own purpose and so we're still in this
process where both coalition partners
thinking maybe there's something we can
get out of it and the Social Democrats
are still in the process of just
limiting the damage that has been done
and saving their personnel that has been
not in office then so there's no legal
problem for them but political problems
who has told the the fact to whom at
what time why did as we mentioned before
mr. Obermann the the chief whip of the
surfer democrats make public the fact
that he had been informed by the
minister of NTA and thereby just
sacrificing him because it must have
been clear to him if if he gives this
factor of the public then the minister
will have to go and so so the surfer
democrats are just trying to chip
to polish the facade at the moment and
the others are thinking well what can we
again what can we get out of them as a
reward for sacrificing own minister and
the CDU and certainly the CSU is fuming
they want a so-called tit for tat they
want heads rolling on the other aisle
namely on the side of the Social
Democrats and do you think that will
happen do you think we will see more
people resigning due to the scandal I I
doubt it I think the main sort of victim
or the mains of whipping boys been
singled out and that was the former
interior minister with the free Jewish
obviously the CSU being a Bavarian part
in he being a member of that party would
like to want some revenge but to whether
it is going to happen I don't think so
doesn't going to be any more
resignations and there's something very
nasty comes out of the woodwork some
politician in the SPD's identified as
the person who tipped off mr. a dirty in
that case yes there would be but I don't
think that that will come out somehow
excess annamaya regardless of whether
further politicians will resign or not a
lot of people say in Germany the damages
are already being done as far as the
erosion of confidence in German politics
on the part of its citizens the fact
that as you pointed out earlier
politicians can do whatever they want to
do disregard the law and bend the law as
they please do you think this will have
further ramifications as far as the
political you know lack of policemen on
the part of its citizens there is again
of course a kind of a disillusionment
with the citizens because they say oh my
god we thought they do that and now they
do all that you know what they really do
it but at the same time to be on the
positive side it came out you know and
it came out and it's being dealt with
and people will look at it and I don't
think something like that's going to
happen again because now we have this
discussion the rule of law you know it
doesn't des apply for politicians as
well so they have to live up to it and I
think that's a very healthy thing in a
democracy that you you actually point
out what goes wrong and then you try to
move on and
to learn from that and in that way I
think it might be unpleasant and might
be for some of the politicians very
embarrassing even but it has to be dealt
with and it has to be spoken about and
they have to know that the rule of law
applies for them like everybody else and
if they don't they don't obey they have
to bear the consequences now but I think
they will there might be a lasting
damage in the way this coalition is
going to work or has to work because the
the now often mentioned mr. Offerman
he's he's sitting at a key position in
this great coalition because he's he's
the one who has to make the deals with
his opposite number in the CDU in them
in the larger coalition party being the
leader of the faction or chief whip or
however you call him least when he has
to organize the majorities in in
Parliament for the coalition and so he
is the one part of this key link where
trust is the main currency you need to
have to to get your deals done and as
long as he is under fire the the other
side other side will say look we do have
a problem here so he has to offer some
kind of well behaving or some kind of
symbol to get this trust restored but if
I say that there's more at stake than
the coalition it's they all try to say
it's about the coalition but it's not
about the coalition only it's also about
trust in politics and I think that is
the main issue that you know looking at
politicians people don't necessarily see
that the Coalition is the state I mean
the state is more than the coalition so
I think there's some things yeah because
things they are everything because they
have this huge majority and they're very
difficult to control and in that sense
it might be a good thing that things
like that come out because with the big
majority you have to be responsible and
more responsible even then you have to
be anyway i don't-- that's-- that's the
worrying thing i think that about
Germany as a whole that you've got a
coalition government which is so unequal
in its makeup we've got a huge majority
that was but albeit not big enough for
an absolute majority held by the
Conservatives and the small part of this
coalition is held by the Social
Democrats the Social Democrats
throughout this thing going to be
wanting to make their mark to make their
name to come out of it with something
will they be able to this is the
question that they might jump ship in
the middle of it and and say we don't
want to do it anymore they might
consider an alliance with the former
communist we don't know and some
analysts are already predicting that
this coalition might not last then hold
the four years that it set out to hold
but one apparent problem that I think we
all agree on is that there's no shortage
and lack of serious topics that need to
be tackled in Germany we're talking
about pension reform we're talking about
energy reform we're talking about the
eurozone crisis the euro crisis that
obviously hasn't gone away yet if the
coalition is distracted with this
scandal how detrimental is this well
there are some people would say we don't
need this pension reform not of the kind
they are planning to do it at all in any
way but I think now they have formed
they've done this 100 pages coalition
agreement they will stick to it for a
while so I think still both parts of the
quill is not interested to to go on with
the government and get this through I
think they're so you go on when
everybody's so distracted with the
scandal when every when all the
resources and energies are going into
cleaning up this mess they just will you
will see you know they'll just because
as you say their interest is all of them
want to stay in this government because
they gain nothing with new elections so
they all will try to work very hard and
it will be verbally it's a big deal but
I think after a short while this is not
going to be forgotten or no they will
use it whenever they can but I think
they will just keep going you know
I'm pretty positive about that it might
change the attitude though I mean the
form of government we we had started
with very high esteem high esteem with
high hopes and then ruined its
reputation within I don't know a couple
of months so so there are some fears
this just might have happened again now
that they just gave away all their all
their power and all their image and
steam their head in the beginning and
now we're just limping on and dragging
on for another four years but I think
the chance is more they will limp on
then they will just split well Jeremy
limping on is no good news for the
European Union which is going to hold
its election short short time from now
in May and a lot of countries on the
continent are looking for German
leadership here how worrying is this
whole political inner political mess in
Germany to Germany's role and and two
responsibilities as one of the key
figures here well I think to be fair I
think that this particular crisis is a
very much seen within Germany and it
hasn't really got outside that much
nobody's sort of saying help you know
that the future of Chancellor Angela
Merkel's coalition is in danger and
thing like that the most outside
observers Germany is Angela Merkel and
we have a coalition government where
there is very little sort of visible
disagreement from the outside and that
represents a degree of stability
providing of course that this minor
crisis and those sets of minor crisis
will be cleared up quickly if it's
allowed to rumble on then it could and
people stop more head start rolling then
it could become very difficult but I
think it's been cape contained so far
just well certainly there hasn't been
much interest and coverage outside of
Germany about the subject matter but
they're certainly in abundance and no
lack of coverage here within Germany and
many people are asking and also perhaps
criticizing that before we can get to
the judicial
use Asians and court of law the media
and the public court of law has already
made up its mind and that is not a very
it's not a first in German politics not
even in recent German politics as we
know let's have a quick look in Germany
a number of celebrity missteps have
played out big in the media's echo
chamber former German President
Christian Wulff stepped down in 2012
accused of accepting favors while in
public office some say he was the victim
of a witch hunt by Germany's yellow
press two years later he is expected to
be fully rehabilitated by a German Court
a different story for Bayern Munich
president uli hoeness despite having
admitted to large-scale tax evasion he
still enjoys the support of his club his
trial is due to start in March taxes
were also the stumbling block for
prominent feminist Ally schmotzer she
received much unwanted media attention
after her admission of tax evasion was
leaked does the boundary between
warranted public interest and celebrity
voyeurism need to be redefined well you
wanna slide toys that we just saw the
various examples in recent and even
current German political landscape now
the public courts of law if you will
many people are arguing is much more
damaging than anything the actual court
of law can inflict the that's why I want
to ask you about the role of the media
in Germany are we too quick all way too
quick to judge a way too quick to report
on these kind of things should we show a
bit more restraint I think there's no
general yes or no for that sometimes
maybe yes often no because there clearly
is a role for the media here and
especially in this times we were just
talking about it when you have a kind of
government with such a large majority
there's no too powerful opposition so
the media have a very very important
role and I wouldn't say in this case we
have been talking about that they have
overstepped the mark maybe with the form
of federal present
Christian will sometime but that's
that's gone and ago but I wouldn't say I
wouldn't say this for thee for the
actual thing senem I would you agree a
lot of people said especially in light
of the coverage visa V Christian Wulff a
lot of people I said we made too much of
it much ado about nothing we destroy the
reputation we destroyed a political
figure now we are slowly finding out
there's really not much me to the story
do you feel the same here I would say
generally speaking that is Troy
themselves but the media's role is to
report we do that we do it correctly I
think sometimes we overstep I think
Kristen wolf is a good example where it
was almost a hunt more than reporting
but I think sometimes the the sheer
quantity of reporting and the total
focus is a problem so if every front
page in the country is dealing with a
dotty orcas teen wolf or whoever or ally
strata and nobody else is covering the
news of the world or the news we also
have to deal with like energy reform all
these things that are really really
important then I think it gets a little
bit out of hand it's not so much the
content even though sometimes some
people over step is always like
everywhere you know people are you have
to specify that but or you have to look
at the specific case some commentators
do but other stone but i think the the
mere quantity and the focus on these
things is maybe a little exaggerated
it's only patterson one country that
hardly ever shows restraint when it
comes to political panic is great
britain to throw the ball out to you
you've already alluded and suggested
that this story would have been covered
very differently in great britain yes i
think because of the concerns have been
raised about child pornography in
general in britain that it's a it has
become a live issue and it's every
politician is concerned with it i think
that in general given the fact that you
in the wolf case it i think there is
some justification to say that was a bit
of a war witch hunt but at the same time
this person was the president of the
country so perhaps that was justified
but I think son is right in the sense
that one the media does tend to take
issues single issues and blow them up
very much they become one issue stories
the country becomes fixated with it
there are other things going on at the
same time so there is a tendency to do
that but the time span I think that
these stories occupy the media is is
shorter than it might have been before I
agree I agree with that the topics come
the topics go and before you know before
you actually get all the information you
really need like in this case we already
switch to another scandal that happens
but that's a natural with media I'm
afraid to say what lessons you learn is
light toys are after the smoke and here
is all gone and after we know allegedly
perhaps know all the facts and heads
have been has a role what lessons are to
be learned here for German politicians
well for the ones that are in it at the
moment I think they have to to think
over their crisis management severely I
mean there there has been has been no
talks and no no plan formed how to
handle this before they went public and
that's why it blew up in their faces so
much to the extent it did so I think
they will have they start there has
already been a meeting of the three
heads of the three coalition parties
meaning Christian Democrats and their
Bavarian partner and the Social
Democrats so they're trying to find ways
to form new trusts but I think they have
to they have to agree on some mechanisms
how to deal with cases like this in the
future because the other Maya what is
the lesson you just tell the truth from
the get-go not necessarily I think they
have to be less casual about the
division of power for example and take
the Constitution a little bit more
seriously and for us the press it means
we really have to watch them we have to
watch them very closely because when
they're in their little bubble of
politics they seem to forget about the
essentials sometimes not necessarily
because they're evil anything it's just
comes with the turf maybe and
that is something they have to be aware
of and they have to learn from that
though other countries such as the
Ukraine would envy us for our problems
nevertheless people trust in
institutions and politicians and the
rule of law in Germany have been
somewhat hampered and damaged by this
crisis would you agree definitely and I
think I'd agree very much what Christian
was saying that the press the role of
the press is very important in Germany
now and I think they've been doing
actually a pretty good job on this they
picked up pretty fast and what was going
on and because of the construction of
this coalition we've got the country's
two major parties in ER in government
there's no real opposition here in
Germany I mean what we got the greens
and the dlink the Left Party minor
parties by comparison that is all that
makes it that much more important the
presses up to the mark and following
exactly what they do and that the
government is on its toes to get rid of
the effect with get rid of just giving
the impression that they're in bed with
each other which is sends the wrong
message and one consistent factor you on
a slide out there is that Chancellor
Merkel has once again proven that she is
a Teflon Chancellor even this scandal
does not touch her yes of course she has
not been excited at all by this but just
done her things dismissed her minister
in a very calm way so that's the thing
you can rely on if you want do you think
this coalition will last for four years
yes briefly well couldn't be more
briefly the other couldn't have been
more briefer we will see whether this
coalition will last for the next four
years for now I want to thank my guests
for shedding some light also to our
viewers worldwide about what this
political scandal has and is all about I
want to thank you out there for tuning
in and we will of course continue to
follow the story as it unfolds to happen
looking forward to seeing you again next
week for a new edition of cod Rica
I